if you're somebody like Sandra pachai or
Sam Altman at the head of a company like
this you're saying if they develop an
AGI they too will lose control of it
so no one person can maintain control no
group of individuals can maintain if
it's if it's created very very soon and
as a big black box that we don't
understand like the large language
models yeah then I'm very confident
they're going to lose control but this
isn't just me saying you know Sam Altman
and then Mr sabis have both said
themselves acknowledge that you know
there's really great risks with this and
they they want to slow down once they
feel it gets scary
it's but it's clear that they're stuck
in this again molok is forcing them to
go a little faster than they're
comfortable with because of pressure
from just commercial pressures right
to get a bit optimistic here of course
this is a problem that can be ultimately
solved uh
it's just to win this wisdom race
it's clear that what we hope that is
going to happen hasn't happened the the
capability progress has gone faster than
a lot of people thought than and the
part the progress in in the public
sphere of policy making and so on has
gone slower than we thought even the
technical AI safety has gone slower a
lot of the technical Safety Research was
kind of banking on that um
large language models and other poorly
understood systems couldn't get us all
the way that you had to build more of a
kind of intelligence that you could
understand maybe it could prove itself
safe you know things like this
and um
I'm quite confident that this can be
done um so we can reap all the benefits
but we cannot do it
as quickly as uh this is out of control
Express train we're on now is gonna get
the AGI that's why we need a little more
time I feel
is there something to be said well like
Sam Allman talked about which is while
we're in the pre-agi stage
to release often and as transparently as
possible to learn a lot
so as opposed to being extremely
cautious release a lot don't uh don't
invest in a closed development where you
focus on AI safety while is somewhat
dumb
quote unquote
uh release as often as possible and as
you start to see signs of
uh human level intelligence or
superhuman level intelligence then you
put a halt on it well
a lot of safety researchers have been
saying for many years is that the most
dangerous things you can do with an AI
is first of all teach it to write code
yeah because that's the first step
towards recursive self-improvement which
can take it from AGI to much higher
levels okay oops we've done that
and uh another thing high risk is
connected to the internet Let It Go to
websites download stuff on its own and
talk to people
oops we've done that already you know
Elias yukowski you said you interviewed
him recently right yes yes so he had
this tweet recently which I
God gave me one of the best laughs in a
while where he's like hey people used to
make fun of me and say you're so stupid
Eliezer because you're saying you're
saying um
you have to worry of obviously
developers once they get to like really
strong AI first thing you're going to do
is like never connect it to the internet
Keep It In The Box yeah where you know
you can really study it if
so he had written it in the like in the
meme form so it's like then yeah and
then that and then now
LOL let's make a chatbot
yeah yeah and the third thing is Stuart
Russell yeah you know
amazing AI researcher he
he has argued for a while that
we should never teach AI anything about
humans
above all we should never let it learn
about human psychology and how you
manipulate humans
that's the most dangerous kind of
knowledge you can give it yeah you can
teach it all it needs to know how about
how to cure cancer and stuff like that
but don't let it read Daniel kahneman's
book about cognitive biases and all that
and then
oops lol you know let's invent social
media
I'll recommender algorithms which do
exactly that they they get so good at
knowing us and pressing our buttons
that we've we're starting to create a
world now where we just have ever more
hatred
because they figured out that these
algorithms not for out of evil but just
to make money on Advertising that the
best way to get more engagement
the euphemism
get people glued to their little
rectangles right it's just to make them
pissed off that's really interesting
that a large AI system that's doing the
recommender system kind of task on
social media is basically just studying
human beings because it's a bunch of us
rats giving it signal
non-stop signal it'll show a thing and
it will give signal on whether we spread
that thing we like that thing that thing
increases our engagement gets us to
return to the platform and it has that
on the scale of hundreds of millions of
people constantly so it's just learning
and learning and learning and presumably
if the param the number of parameters in
your neural network that's doing the
learning and more end to end the
learning is
the more it's able to just basically
encode how to manipulate human behavior
how to control humans at scale exactly
and that is not something you think is
in Humanity's interest
yeah right now it's mainly letting some
humans manipulate other humans for
profit
and Power
which already
caused a lot of damage and eventually
that's a sort of
skill that can make ai's persuade humans
to let them Escape
whatever safety precautions we put you
know there was a really nice article um
and the New York Times recently by
you've all know a Harari and and two
co-authors including Tristan Harris from
the social dilemma and
they have this phrase in there I love
Humanity's first contact with Advanced
AI
on social media
and we lost that one
we now live in a country where there's
much more hate in the world where
there's much more hate in fact
and in our democracy that we're having
this conversation then people can't even
agree on who won the last election you
know
and we humans often point fingers at
other humans and say it's their fault
but it's really moloch and these AI
algorithms
we got the algorithms and then molok
pitted the social media companies are
against each other so nobody could have
a less creepy algorithm because then
they would lose out on our Revenue to
the other company is there any way to
win that battle back just if we just
Linger on this one battle that we've
lost in terms of social media is it
possible
to redesign social media this very
medium in which we use as a civilization
to communicate with each other to have
these kinds of conversations to have
discourse to try to figure out how to
solve the biggest problems in the world
whether that's nuclear war or the
development of AGI is is it possible
uh to do social media correct I think
it's not only possible but it's it's
necessary who are we kidding that we're
going to be able to solve all these
other challenges if we can't even have a
conversation with each other it's
constructive the whole idea the key idea
of democracy is that you get a bunch of
people together
and they have a real conversation the
ones you try to Foster on this podcast
or you respectfully listen to people you
disagree with
and you realize actually you know there
are some things actually we some common
ground we have and that's it's yeah we
both agree let's not have a nuclear Wars
let's not do that
um etc etc
we're kidding ourselves thinking we can
face off the
second contact with whatever more
powerful AI that's happening now with
this large language models if we can't
even
have a functional
conversation in the public space that's
why I started to improve the news
project improve the news.org but um
I I'm an optimist fundamentally in um
and that there is a lot of intrinsic
goodness
in in in people
and that uh what makes the difference
between someone doing good things for
for Humanity and bad things is not
some sort of fairy tale thing that this
person was born with the evil Gene and
this one is not born with a good Gene no
I think it's whether we put whether
people
find themselves in situations that bring
out the best in them or they bring out
the worst in them and I feel we're
building an internet
and a society that brings out the worst
but it doesn't have to be that way no it
does not it's possible to create
incentives and also create incentives
that make money they both make money and
bring out the best in people I mean in
the long term it's not a good investment
for anyone you know to have a nuclear
war for example
and you know is it a good investment for
Humanity if we just ultimately replace
all humans by machines and then we're so
obsolete that eventually the
there are no humans left
well it depends against how you do the
math but like if I would say by any
reasonable it cannot be started if you
look at the future income of humans and
there aren't any you know that's not a
good investment
moreover like why why can't we have a
little bit of pride in our species damn
it you know why should we just build
another species that gets rid of us if
we were Neanderthals
would we really consider it a smart move
if the
if we had really Advanced biotech to
build homo sapiens
you you know you might say hey Max you
know yeah let's build build the
these Homo sapiens they're going to be
smarter than us maybe they can help us
defend us better against the Predators
and help fix up our caves make them
nicer and we'll control them undoubtedly
you know so then they build build a
couple a little baby girl little baby
boy you know and
and then you have some some wise old and
the enderthal Elder was like hmm I'm
scared that uh we're opening in
Pandora's Box here and that we're gonna
get outsmarted by these
super Neanderthal intelligences and
there won't be any neanderthals left and
then but then you have a bunch of others
in the cave are you such a Luddite
scaremonger or of course they're going
to want to keep us around because we are
their creators and and why you know the
smart I think the smarter they get the
nicer they're gonna get they're gonna
leave us they're gonna
they're gonna want this around and it's
going to be fine and and besides look at
these babies they're so cute
it's clearly they're totally harmless
that's exact those babies are exactly
gpt4 yeah it's not I want to be clear
it's not gpt4
that's terrifying it's the gpt4 is a
baby technology
you know at Microsoft even had a paper
recently out
the title something like sparkles of AGI
whatever basically saying this is baby
AI
like these little Neanderthal babies
and it's gonna grow up there's gonna be
other systems from from the same company
from other companies they'll be way more
powerful and but they're going to take
all the things
ideas from these babies
and before we know it we're gonna be
like
those last neanderthals who were pretty
disappointed and when they realized that
they were getting replaced well this
interesting point you make which is the
programming is it's entirely possible
that GPT 4 is already the kind of system
that can
change everything
by writing programs sorry it's yeah it's
because it's Life 2.0
the systems I'm afraid of are going to
look nothing like a large language model
and they're not
but once it gets once it or other people
figure out a way of using this Tech to
make much better Tech right it's just
constantly replacing its software and
from everything we've seen about how how
these work under the hood they're like
the minimum viable intelligence they do
everything you know the dumbest way that
still works sort of yeah and um
so they are live 3.0 except when they
replace their software it's a lot faster
than when you when when you decide to
learn Swedish
and moreover they think a lot faster
than us too so when uh you know
we don't think uh have
one
logical step every nanosecond or a few
or so the way they do and we can't also
just suddenly scale up our Hardware
massively in the cloud because we're so
limited right
so they are and they are also life have
consumed become a little bit more like
life 3.0 and that if they need more
Hardware hey just rent it in the cloud
you know how do you pay for it well with
all the services you provide